[Music]
how do we know whether an object in
motion is traveling faster or slower
than another object consider two objects
object one and object to both moving
along the same path just by looking at
their motion can you tell me which one
of them is moving faster clearly this
one is moving faster in comparison to
object one object two keeps lagging
behind hence we say that the speed of
object one is more than the speed of
object two speed is that physical
quantity which tells us how fast
something is moving how do we define it
in order to know the speed of an object
there are just two things we need to
know first the distance traveled by an
object in motion and second the time it
takes to complete that distance consider
a car moving on a straight road first of
all can you tell the type of motion its
undergoing since it's moving in a
straight line it's in a rectilinear
motion suppose the time it takes to
reach the other side is 30 seconds now
consider another car which is similar to
the first one it's also moving in a
straight line path adjacent to the first
one the time taken by this red car to
cover the same length of the road is 40
seconds the blue car covered the path
length in 30 seconds while the red car
covered the same path length in 40
seconds which one of them was moving
with greater speed by intuition we can
say that the blue colored car was
traveling at a greater speed than the
red one why because the blue car covered
the same distance in lesser time let the
length of this path be 420 meters this
pot length is nothing but the distance
that the car travels in a given amount
of time now for each object if we take
the ratio of the total distance covered
and the time required to cover that
distance we will get this this ratio is
called the speed of the object
yes speed is distance over time since
this ratio is greater than this one it
means that the blue car traveled with
greater speed let's bring in a third car
which covers the same distance in 20
seconds so what does it speed then the
speed is 420 meters over 20 seconds
which will give us 21 meters per second
and you can see that this ratio is the
greatest of all now I want you to look
at the unit's meters per second is one
of the units of speed there are many
such units of speed that you must be
aware of for example kilometers per hour
miles per hour feet per minute and so on
we will discuss more about these units
enough future videos let's discuss
something interesting now look at the
example of one of the cars the car a the
only information I gave you was that it
covers 420 meters in 30 seconds that
gave us the speed as 14 meters per
second I want you to answer the next
question I'm asking you in this example
can we say that the speed of the car a
is constant throughout this distance R
we say that the car is covering 14
meters every second through off the path
no that's not what we're implying
because maybe the car is moving at a
really fast speed initially and that it
slows down in the middle and then stops
and then again speeds up so this beat
does not imply that the speed is
constant at 14 meters per second
throughout so what is the speed then the
speed we calculated here is the average
speed in fact in all the three examples
it was average speed how do we define it
average speed is defined as the total
distance traveled by an object divided
by the total time taken we will continue
to discuss more about average speed in
our next video
[Music]
you